[Music]
New York Times columnist Maureen Dowd
wrote a hammering a harrowing account of
being high on edible marijuana in a
Denver hotel room that's right she she
took the edible marijuana and then she
experienced it at time had a really bad
time and she wrote about it she said it
was a nightmarish experience for her and
it's clear that when eaten when you
actually eat it pot can be quite potent
we actually very potent and
what was that is everything okay with
the camera Bob oh yeah sorry Connie just
little slip won't happen again
oh it's okay anyway comment advice for
people who feel - hi is just breathe
just keep on breathing it was close he's
onto me you probably notice I ate an
entire weed rice krispies treat just
before the show yeah he definitely knows
and then that way the feeling will pass
and you will return to normal I promise
it's very simply Betty also knows that I
sometimes steal yogurts out of his
personal fridge
he probably counts them every night so
whatever you do don't try to drive or
operate any heavy machinery because that
heavy machinery he means this camera
okay relax
at least you can't hear what I'm
thinking or candy maybe everyone can
know that that's crazy
keep it together Brad I mean Bob crap
I'm so high I don't even know my own
name you see it's just important to
remember you will get through this you
just gonna get fired on air I know it or
might just being paranoid hey what's
with that new camera man
I can't take it anymore I gotta get up
there
[Music]
my god Andy why did Bob the cameraman
just change clothes and then jump out of
a whip
go up five stories shut up whitey change
clothes go up five stories and jump out
a window what's going on with him
I don't know Conan why is he asking me
does he know I supply the entire staff
with weed rice krispie treats and then I
ate two of them during the commercial
break
keep it together Andy everything's fine
Andy Andy are you okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
folks we'll take a break we'll be right
you